[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
all right and we
we saw a gentleman that we have in the
realm of Past Quest today well my name
is Jacob Burgess I'm director of
operations for yesterday
's developers are switch Factory
okay
all right you want to do that while I'm
playing there
[Music]
action teams are incredibly great before
setting uh
that's not
what's right
yeah it's a low fantasy setting so it's
low magic uh
almost during the Apocalypse
you kind of find out during the course
of the gameplay is
dying
it's the story of a solution
so how far a father would go to keep
family
[Music]
uh we've got uh here we've got different
types of difficulty settings even though
this is uh inspired by Devil May Cry and
souls like games absolutely brutal uh
you can send it on the story mode
they've got a bunch of different like
[Music]
like you guys
[Music]
how you want to approach and play the
game yep you can play the game at your
pace uh if you really hate yourself uh
you can send it on foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
math which means everything right
we're waiting for the Last Guardian to
pass on so we've been
far too long
if there's a podcast if you want to read
out the dialogue
and it really tried to tell a story the
house they see a lot of hacks coming up
so you can play
them front to finish
a really really dive into the building
you can start from with
how they develop
[Music]
ment
[Music]
even if you won't see the whole thing
thing
around so in that like in that way not
just combat but also in that way
from software games like this they
really really love
so there's stuff that we may never
encounters
this is
your job
information
yeah yeah
they let you know what they're about
foreign
very cool
got those two trailer songs on Spotify
too
you gotta love him again
that's what brought like yeah
[Music]
one of the things that I
sort of reason why there's a dead giant
there with the sword
Bridge yep yeah
we got our quick slap buttons and we're
assigning different tasks to different
effects so we're starting to create
salon
so executions are one of the only ways
to get items from enemies okay
but every item that you pick up has more
associated with it
those are the items that we're acquiring
after the kill yeah
throwing knives different health potions
stamina potions things like that yep
oh it defense actually okay because you
can carry okay
so I don't have a lot of damage for
direct attacks but
he carry at the right time and get their
defense speeder all the way down they'll
enter a stunned state that you can then
do before damage so apparently is a
natural mechanically
yes it can be okay you can just do a
bunch of dodging in like death of a
Thousand Cuts if you want to uh but it
definitely helps do it faster
development like how long has Enterprise
like five years wow it's been a while
before yeah the team has been
has been sweating tears of drama and
approximately how big is the team oh
about seven people wow yeah
but they do I mean I mean
okay wow those things went down oh they
got a little leaf yep he's got tickets
he got snatched
I don't feel
it doesn't go
like there's a lot of tax involved like
I got that guy to shoot the uh
the Archer to shoot
these birds absolutely
I really love it now to get that spring
how you initiating that spread oh it's
automatic well it's automatic okay so
just if you if you go if you move for
example just in a direction for a
certain amount of time it is an auto
screen all right
let's get back
and as far as like inventory authorities
getting new weapons
uh it's not I mean the inventory is for
like the items that you find like
throwing knives bear traps
there are I don't want to give any
spoilers but we're
like
[Music]
obviously those are the same things
those are yes
Giant on there
[Music]
okay
he's stunned and now you see the parents
definitely picked up
it can be parried as well so if you're
just by Magic on certain enemies
sometimes they'll walk you
away
exactly
and
delicious very impressive
sorry thank you
oh let's get him
here
dressing me
let's put that boy waddle okay okay now
we got the ceremonial Malibu
of Desmond all right
this looks so yeah well let's be sure
you're the
uh
I'm getting cracked somebody over the
head over there Mommy
thank you
because there's those defense damage as
well
as far as like
the gameplay
12 hours
and again
all at that all stuff for the puzzle to
get it so they got scary and this is
given me Zelda valve and it's loving
that yeah
it's okay we're looking at all platforms
uh right now
um
I got a shout out my steam deck uh
hopefully not official no announcements
right here
[Music]
that's cool
okay
hey I'm sorry I'm sold I'm in so if you
want me to sell your audience on this
game yeah this game will kick your ass
and break your heart
September 22nd September 22nd so which
does not steam let us know what you uh
let us know that you want the game we'll
let you know when it's out pick it up
make the numbers go Bird yeah you
already heard it first absolutely nice
job
for everything a lot of the iops
favorite we got a high on it we heard
when it's coming up go check it out La
Cognito approved it's very lordly for
the proof
see you later
good thank you sir
[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords